as Julius Robert Oppenheimer witnessed
the successful detonation of the world's
first nuclear weapon he was haunted by
its implications I remembered the
line from the Hindu scripture of the
bhagavad-gita
now I am become death
the destroyer of worlds
I suppose we all thought that one way or
another
Oppenheimer was a man of many talents he
spoke eight languages wrote poetry yet
he will forever be remembered as the
father of the atomic bomb
the man who gave people the power to
destroy themselves was haunted by his
own creation
when people first met J Robert
Oppenheimer what was immediately obvious
to them was his intellect a former
colleague once said the man was
unbelievable he always gave you the
right answer before you formulated the
question knowledge came easy to
Oppenheimer he learned Dutch in six
weeks just so he could give a lecture
while on a visit to the Netherlands
he was born in New York on April 22nd
1904. the older son of German Jewish
immigrants his father Julius was a
textile importer who became very wealthy
his mother was a painter whose family
had been in New York for Generations he
was raised in Manhattan on the upper
west side in an apartment adorned with
paintings by famous artists including
Van Gogh after attending an elite
private school in New York City he went
on to Harvard in 1922 intending to
become a chemist but leaving with an
appetite for physics
he had been attracted to experimental
physics after taking a course on
thermodynamics at Harvard he also
studied philosophy Greek and French
literature he spent his days living in
the library raiding the place
intellectually as he put it he enrolled
at Harvard a year late due to suffering
from colitis and inflammatory bowel
disease but he made up for it by
graduating in three years instead of
four he then crossed the pond to the
University of Cambridge to conduct
research at the Cavendish laboratory for
experimental physics however he was
clumsy in the lab and realized his Forte
was not an experimental work but rather
in theoretical physics
the stress of grad work threw him into
depression and he became emotionally
unstable he even confessed to Lacing an
apple with harmful chemicals in an
attempt to poison his tutor with whom he
didn't get along
fortunately the tutor didn't eat the
apple
Oppenheimer left Cambridge to continue
his studies at one of the centers of
theoretical physics in Europe the
University of godingen in Germany he
produced good work and held his own
despite his youth he was only 23 years
old when he received his PhD he
subsequently returned to the U.S where
he worked as a research fellow at
Harvard and then the California
Institute of Technology Caltech he was
so absorbed in his studies that he often
ignored the real world
but the rise of fascism in Europe in the
1930s caught his attention
Oppenheimer agreed with Einstein that
German scientists could make a nuclear
weapon and when they did Hitler was
prepared to use it
America watched fearfully as the Nazis
invaded Poland in 1939. in 1942
Oppenheimer was selected to direct the
Manhattan Project a top-secret U.S army
project to develop the atomic bomb
he brought together the best Minds in
physics and eventually managed more than
3 000 people
he chose Los Alamos New Mexico as a
primary production facility because of
its natural beauty he had fallen in love
with the mountains and plateaus when he
traveled there as a teen during his Gap
year as he recovered from ill health
Washington threw ridiculous amounts of
money at the project an initial budget
of six thousand dollars eventually
ballooned into a whopping 2 billion by
1945
before heading the Manhattan Project
Oppenheimer taught physics at both
Caltech and the University of California
Berkeley where he built the physics
program and turned it into the hub for
physics research in America
he had already been working on nuclear
fission The Powerful release of energy
caused by the splitting of an atom the
best element for splitting is the
heaviest element found in nature uranium
a uranium atom has 92 protons and 146
neutrons giving an atomic mass of 238 or
u-238 a small portion of uranium that's
mined has the same 92 protons however it
only has 143 neutrons giving us u-235
this is highly unstable which makes it
highly splitable or fissionable
when it's slammed by Neutron it becomes
u-236 it's so unstable that it splits
into two atoms Krypton and barium in the
process three more neutrons are released
they fly out and slam into more u-235
atoms causing a chain reaction and
ultimately a huge explosion kinda like
when you throw a bowling ball and the
pins jump and strike other pins and
those pins smash into other pins all of
the energy is released research also
showed that plutonium-239 would be
highly fissionable however it's not a
naturally occurring element and had to
be manufactured reactors were built in
Southeastern Washington State to produce
the plutonium
and then on July 16 1945 scientists
detonated a plutonium bomb over the
small town of Alamogordo New Mexico we
knew the world would not be the same
few people
laughed
few people cried
most people were silent
never before had Humanity possessed a
weapon that posed a threat to human
civilization the test success meant an
atomic bomb was ready to be used by the
U.S military
the following month the U.S military
dropped two atomic bombs on Japan on
August 6 1945 the most powerful weapon
in the world was dropped on the Japanese
city of Hiroshima 140
000 people were killed many vaporized
thousands more would die in pain in the
months and years that followed from
radiation poisoning
three days later another bomb fell on
Nagasaki killing 74 000 people with
equally devastating effects
Japanese emperor Hirohito decried the
devastating power of a new and most
cruel Bond Japan surrendered six days
later abruptly ending World War II
Oppenheimer initially expressed guilt
over his creation he said the weapon had
dramatized so mercilessly the inhumanity
an evil of War he continued in some sort
of crude sense which no vulgarity no
humor no overstatements can quite
extinguish the physicists have known sin
and this is a knowledge which they
cannot lose
yet a decade later he appeared to
distance himself from personal
responsibility
hitting it on the state saying I carry
no weight on my conscience
our work has changed the conditions in
which men live but the use made of these
changes is the problem of governments
not of scientists
after the war he became a key advisor on
U.S Atomic policy he headed the
principal advisory committee of the
successor to the Manhattan Project the
atomic energy commission the commission
was a civilian agency in control of
nuclear research and the development of
nuclear weapons he even had a desk in
the president's executive offices across
the street from the White House
but then things began to turn against
Oppenheimer in December 1953 president
Dwight Eisenhower ordered that a blank
wall be placed between Dr Oppenheimer
and any secret data
Oppenheimer was suspected of being a
communist spy he argued he was never
interested in politics and economics he
apparently wasn't even aware of the
stock market crash of 1929 until after
the fact however he started connecting
with left-leaning groups in the 30s and
40s after falling for Gene tatlock
foreign
1936 friends introduced Oppenheimer to
the grad student who was studying
psychology at Stanford tatlock was
extremely involved with politics she was
a member of the Communist Party of
America and supported many left-leaning
causes Oppenheimer inherited hundreds of
thousands of dollars after his father's
death in the 30s and began supporting
left-wing efforts such as the loyalists
in the Spanish Civil War
they had a passionate relationship and
were together for several years coming
close to marriage but ultimately broke
up
he went on to marry Kitty punting in
1940. she was a Berkeley student and was
at one time a Communist Party member
they had two children together
he still continued to see his former
love and spent a night with tatlock
while working on the secret bomb project
in 1943 tatlock told him she still loved
him he never saw her again
she was a complicated person and is said
to have struggled with her sexuality she
also suffered from intense depression
and would take her own life in 1944.
perhaps it was tatlock's love of the
English poet John Dunn that compelled
Oppenheimer to name the first test of
the atomic bomb Trinity inspired by dun
sonnet about a three-person to God
although oppenheimer's communist
affiliations were clearly known they
didn't stop him from getting hired on to
lead the Manhattan Project the FBI saw
no reason to revoke his security
clearance when they conducted an
investigation in 1944. however the onset
of the Cold War brought renewed scrutiny
the Soviet Union conducted its first
nuclear test in 1949. ahead of America's
estimates people within the government
were suspicious of Oppenheimer William
liskin Borden executive director of the
United States Congress joint committee
on atomic energy had sent a letter to
FBI director J Edgar Hoover concluding
more probably than not J Robert
Oppenheimer is an agent of the Soviet
Union
he didn't back up his claim with any
solid evidence Borden was close to the
chairman of the atomic energy commission
Lewis Strauss who hated Oppenheimer the
two butted heads and Strauss never
forgot when Oppenheimer humiliated him
at a congressional hearing years earlier
in 1954 Oppenheimer was called before a
tribunal of the atomic energy commission
to explain his communist affiliations it
was a closed-door hearing that lasted
four weeks
Oppenheimer maintained that he had not
been radicalized by his ex-partner and
said his left-wing friends and
associations simply gave him a sense of
companionship nothing more he had never
been a Communist Party member himself
three board members heard his case by a
vote of two to one they stripped him of
a security clearance
the guy who delivered the verdict was
none other than Strauss who hated him
Oppenheimer was humiliated
the once powerful scientist lost all his
power the U.S government no longer
trusted the U.S government's top Atomic
physicist
his scientific peers were outraged
Einstein quipped that the aec in atomic
energy commission actually stood for
Atomic extermination conspiracy Werner
Von Brown the Chief Architect of the
Saturn V that got us to the Moon
declared in England Oppenheimer would
have been knighted by the way I did a
story on Von Braun's past as a Nazi
scientist which I'll link in the
description
but at least one scientist was pleased
with the outcome Hungarian physicist
Edward Teller resented to the fact that
Oppenheimer resisted working on the
hydrogen bomb which is a more advanced
version of an atomic bomb when President
Truman approached the Commission in 1949
about building a hydrogen bomb
Oppenheimer opposed it to the anger of
teller the U.S pressed ahead with
developing a thermonuclear weapon anyway
and tested it in 1952 on the Marshall
Islands
the h-bomb became teller's baby during
the Oppenheimer hearing teller testified
I would feel personally more secure if
public matters would rest in other hands
for his testimony teller was shunned by
the scientific Community for many years
today hundreds of Declassified pages
from the secret hearings have revealed
Oppenheimer was not disloyal the U.S
department of energy concludes it proved
impossible to link his lack of
enthusiasm for the hydrogen bomb with
suspicions of his disloyalty
producing another weapon with the
potential to be a thousand times more
powerful than the atomic bomb was
unfathomable to Oppenheimer he felt the
hydrogen bomb was unnecessary and
immoral fearing its use against
civilians he had used his position on
the atomic energy commission to lobby
for international control of nuclear
weapons to avoid a nuclear arms race
with the Soviet Union
with the security clearance revoked he
settled in Princeton New Jersey where he
still ran the institute for advanced
study a research facility for
post-doctoral fellows
he lived quietly until President John F
Kennedy invited him to the White House
dinner of Nobel Prize winners in 1962.
Oppenheimer never won a Nobel Prize
himself though he was nominated for The
Prize in physics three times
when the Kennedy administration offered
him a new trial to potentially get his
security clearance back he declined
further evidence that the government was
warming up to him came in 1963 when
President Johnson awarded him one of the
highest scientific honors bestowed by
President the Fermi award which comes
with fifty thousand dollars tax-free in
response Oppenheimer said I think it is
just possible Mr President
that it has taken some charity and some
courage for you to make this award today
two years later in 1965 Oppenheimer was
diagnosed with throat cancer he had been
a notorious chain smoker all his life
the New York Times once described him as
thin as a wisps from his chain-smoked
cigarettes or pipes
on February 18 1967
he died at his home in Princeton he was
62 years old
his wife took his Ashes to the island of
Saint John in the U.S Virgin Islands
where he lived for several months of the
year and spread his ashes in the sea
outside of their home in an area known
today as Oppenheimer Beach
the 20th century marked a new age in
which the very existence of humankind
was threatened
that threat is more real than ever today
with fears that Russia could use nuclear
weapons in Ukraine North Korea's missile
launches in October were a simulation to
wipe out South Korean targets according
to State media
the Doomsday Clock warns we are getting
closer to destroying our world at the
beginning of the Cold War we were Seven
Minutes to Midnight today we're a
hundred seconds to midnight
if you've been inspired by your story
and wish to improve your science
technology engineering and math skills
brilliant is the best place to start and
it's free to try out if you head to my
custom link
brilliant is super interactive in this
computer science fundamentals course you
learn to program drones in an Amazon
warehouse to help you think
algorithmically and no coding is
required you can make sense of the World
by exploring the laws of physics and the
principles of engineering through their
scientific thinking course instead of
complex mathematics and number crunching
you can learn through physical Insight
by solving puzzles
for math enthusiasts there are so many
mathematics courses to choose from you
can start your algebra Journey with
Brilliance pre-algebra course that will
sharpen your problem-solving skills and
explore what's really useful about
algebra there's something for everyone
on brilliant whether you're a student or
you're already working and want to brush
up on what you already know brilliant is
free for you to sign up if you use the
custom link in my description
brilliant.org newsthink that's
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who sign up with my link will
get 20 off their annual premium
subscription which gives you access to
all of their offerings including their
most advanced courses thanks for
watching for a news think I'm Cindy Palm